Transcriber: Hakan Akgün
Gözden geçirme: Figen Ergürbüz
Prof. Dr. Talat KIRIŞ
Nöroşirürji Uzmanı
Özge ziyaretime geldi.
''Hocam'' dedi.
''19 Mayıs'taki TEDx etkinliğinde
sizi mutlaka aramızda görmek istiyoruz.''
Ben hasta yatağımda, öksürükler içinde
halsiz mecalsiz yatarken,
hayır diyemediğimden
''İyi o zaman'' diyebildim.
İşte şimdi aranızdayım.
Ama biraz hınzırca, biraz da inadına,
hüzünlü bir konuşma yapacağım.
Özge benden pozitif
cıvıl cıvıl bir konuşma istemişti.
Bir masal anlatacağım size bugün.
Bir küçük İstanbul masalı.
İçinde doğup büyüdüğüm, sevindiğim,
üzüldüğüm, okullarını okuduğum,
yıllardır insanların
beyinlerini ameliyat ettiğim,
bir dünya kongresinin
başkanlığını yaptığım,
yağmurlarında ıslanıp,
lodos estiğinde bütün
İstanbullular gibi gerildiğim,
bir küçük İstanbul masalı.
Hâlâ gece yarıları tekinsiz sokaklarında
cılız ışıklarda grafitilerini
fotoğrafladığım şehrime dair bir masal.
Bir fotoğraf karesinde,
şehri, maziyi,
hayalleri ve aşkı yeniden
keşfetmek üzerine bir masal.
Masallarda hüzün ile sevinç
yanyana durur ve
gökten elmalar düşerken de
payınıza düşeni alırsınız.
Masallarda gerçek üstü öyküler anlatılır.
Onun için güzeldirler, hayata benzerler ve
hayatımızdaki onca sahteliğin arasında en
samimi hakikatler de masallarda bulunur.
Masal gibi yaşamalı hayatı.
O zaman tek bir geçmişiniz ve
tek bir geleceğiniz olmaz.
Mümkün geçmişleriniz ve
mümkün gelecekleriniz olur.
Anlarınız ve tercihlerinizle şekillenir.
mümkün geçmişleriniz ve gelecekleriniz.
Her zaman masal gibi
yaşadığınızda, tercihlerinizi
hayâllerinizden yana kullanırsınız,
korkmazsınız.
Şimdi Sinbad gibi
dalalım masalımızın içine.
Antarktika'da, Spirit of Sydney
yelkenlisinde,
bir gece,
yedi denizden
mürettabatla içiyorduk.
Kavafis'in şiiri geldi aklıma.
Dedin "bir başka ülkeye gideceğim,
bir başka denize gideceğim.
Bundan daha iyi bir başka ülke
bir başka kent bulunur elbet."
Yeni ülkeler bulamayacaksın,
başka denizler bulamayacaksın.
Bu kent peşini bırakmayacak.
Aynı sokaklarda dolaşacaksın,
aynı mahallede yaşlanacaksın;
Aynı evlerde kır düşecek saçlarına.
Bu kentdir gidip gideceğin yer.
Başkasını umma.
Spirit of Sydney yelkenlisinde,
Antarktika'da, hiçbir kenti olmayan,
o denizin kıyısında,
7 Aralık 2013'te bir kutlama yaptık.
Kızımın doğum gününü
ve başka güzel şeyleri.
Şili şarabı su gibi akıp gitti.
Herkes şarkılar söyledi.
Ben de mürettebata
Türkçe şarkılar dinlettim.
Gecenin bir yarısı
herkes sarhoşken,
kendimizi Fikrimin İnce Gülü'nü
söylerken bulduk.
Sonra herkes ranzalarına
çekilip uyudu.
Ben dışarı çıktım.
Gece saat 3'tü.
Ortalık gündüz gibi aydınlıktı.
Antarktika'nın yazında gece olmuyor.
Spirit of Sydney, Lemaire Kanalı'nda
demirliydi. Karşımızda çenesi çizgili
penguenlerden oluşmuş bir sürü ve
küçük bir fok ailesi vardı.
Deniz çırpıntılı, hava soğuktu.
Penguenler mır mır konuşuyorlardı.
İnce bir kar yağmaya başladı ve
İstanbul peşimden geldi.
Not tuttuğum bir defterim vardı.
Buz dağlarının gri mavi ışıklarında,
yansıyan hayallerimi
sözcüklerle resmettiği.
O defterimin arasında Kavafis'in şiiri,
sararmış bir fotoğraf ve Atilla İlhan'ın
İstanbul Ağrısı yan yana duruyordu.
O fotoğrafta Madam Anahit ile resmimiz,
yaprakların arasından Atilla İlhan'ın
dizelerine dolanmış bana bakıyordu.
İstanbul Ağrısı uzun bir şiirdir.
Hayatımın şiirlerinden biridir aslında.
O şiirde geçen İstanbul'u eski bir kitap
gibi koltuğunun altında götürmek istediği
Sicilyalı balıkçılara Marsilyalı dok
işçilerine satır satır anlatmak
istediği satırlar hayallerimi süslemiştir.
Biraz da onun için denizci olmuşumdur.
Biraz da onun için
yelkenleri öğrenmişimdir.
Ne zaman seyyaleyle
Akdeniz'de bir seyir yapsak
bir limana yanaşırken
o dizeleri hatırlamışımdır.
Spirit of Sydney'in havuzluğunda oturdum,
İstanbul Ağrısı'ndan bir bölüm
okumaya başladım.
"sonbahar karanlıklıları tuttu tutacak
Tarlabaşı pansiyonlarında
bekarlar buğulanıyor
imtihan çığlıkları
yükseliyor üniversiteden
diesel kamyonları
Tophane İskelesi'nde sarhoş
direksiyonlarının koynuna girmiş
bıçkın şoförler uykusuz dalgalanıyor
ulan İstanbul bu sen misin
senin ellerin mi bu eller
ulan bu gemiler senin gemilerin mi
minarelerini kürdan gibi
dişlerinin arasında liman liman götüren
ulan bu mazot tüküren
bu dövmeli gemiler senin mi
akşamlar yassıldıkça
neden böyle devleşiyorlar
neden durmaksızın imdat kıvılcımları
fışkırıyor antenlerinden
neden
peki İstanbul ya ben
ya mısralarını dört renkli
duvar afişleri gibi boy boy
gümrük duvarlarına yapıştıran
yolcu Abbas
ya benim kahrım
ya senin ağrın
ağır kabaranlarınla uykularını ezerek
deliksiz bıraktığın
çaresiz zehirler kusan çılgın bir
yılan gibi burgu burgu içime boşaltığın
o senin ağrın
o senin
sen eğer yine İstanbul'san yanılmıyorsam
koltuğumun altında eski bir kitap diye
götürmek istediğim Sicilyalı balıkçılara
Marsilyalı dok işçilerine
satır satır okumak istediğim sen
eğer yine İstanbul'san
senin ağrınsa iğneli beşik gibi
her tarafımda hissettiğim
ulan yine sen kazandın İstanbul
sen kazandın ben yenildim
kulaklarımdan kan fışkırıncaya
kadar emrindeyim
ölsem yalnız kalsam
parasız kalsam cüzdanım kaybolsa
kimsesiz kalsam tenhalarda kalsam
sen eğer yine İstanbul'san
senin ıslıklarınsa kulaklarıma
saplanan bu ıslıklar
gözbebeklerimde gezegenler
gibi dönen yalnızlığımdan
bir tekmede kapılarını kırıp
çıktım demektir"
(Alkış)
O kapıdan çıktım ve
kendimi yıllar öncesinde
Çiçek Pasajı'nda
Cavit'in Yeri'nde buldum.
Sıkı meyhaneciydi Cavit.
Ağzına içki koymazdı.
Yeşilay üyesiydi.
Kadınları mayfer leydi diye buyur eder,
erkeklere ekselans derdi.
Lakabı, entellektüel Cavit'ti.
Bir kaç yıl önce 80 yaşında öldü.
İlk defa babamla oraya gitmiştik.
18 yaşımdaydım.
Bana meyhane adabını öğretmişti.
Nasıl oturulur? Nasıl kalkılır?
Nasıl içilir?
Ama daha önemlisi, meyhanenin yalnızca
içki içilecek bir yer olmadığını,
ama sohbet edilecek, edebiyat
konuşulacak, şiir konuşulacak,
hatta ders çalışabilecek
bir yer olduğunu öğretmişti.
Sonraları tıbbiyedeyken
daha sık gitmeye başladık.
Bir elimizde temel bilimler notları,
bir elimizde şiir kitapları...
Nazım Hikmet, Hasan Hüseyin,
Can Yücel, Bedri Rahmi.
Sonraları aşk kapıyı çaldığında
Cemal Süreya tabii.
Bir de Özdemir Asaf, bir de Atilla İlhan.
Ağır takılıyorsak Melih Cevdet,
Ece Ayhan, bir de Metin Eloğlu.
Madam Anahit ile
ilk tanışmamız o yıllardı.
Bizler tıfıl öğrencileriz,
Madam ise ağır abla.
Daha bira düzeyindeyiz,
açılmamışız denizlere.
Yine de yazıyoruz kendimizce.
Ben mesela Düşün Dergisi'nin
masal yarışmasına katılmışım.
Soğuk bir İstanbul sabahında
sonuçlar açıklandığında,
ayın ilk günü,
derginin paketini çözen
ilk gazete bayisinde,
orta sayfada adım, yanında masalım.
Daha Dünya Bebekken.
Rahmetli Onat Kutlar'ın elinden ödül almak
bahtiyarlığına da erişmiştim.
Onat Kutlar yıllar sonra Taksim'de,
bir hotelin altında kahvesini yudumlarken,
patlayan bir bomba ile öldürüldüğünde,
bana ödül verirken, Taksim'e her indiğimde
içimde gülen gözlerini taşımıştım.
Daha Dünya Bebekken,
Kuzey Kutbu ile Güney Kutbu'nun
imkansız aşkını anlatan bir masaldı.
Yani kutuplara sevdam o zamanlardan.
Çok gençtim, çok heyecanlıydım ve
yıllar sonra Grönland'tan aldığım bir taşı
Antarktika'da buzların arasına bırakırken,
penguenlerden utanmasam ağlayacaktım.
Masalım gerçek olmuştu,
sevgililer kavuşmuştu.
İstanbul ile el ele tutuşarak
yılları yürüdük.
Beyin cerrahisinde asistandım.
Hayatı her yönüyle yaşamak,
eşek sudan gelinceye kadar yorulup,
yine de geceleri jilet gibi bu şehirle
sevişmek fena halde bize yakışıyordu.
Cavit'in Yeri'nde
üç garson vardı, üç kardeş.
Ben en büyükleri Şevket ile ahbaptım.
Beyaz bir Renault'u vardı.
İçkiyi fazla kaçıranları
geceleri evine bırakırdı.
Akciğer kanserinden öldü.
Kardeşleri Cengiz ile Vedat.
Madam Anahit ile fotoğrafımız
o yıllarda çekilmişti.
Beyin cerrahisi dergilerinde
makalelerim yayınlanmaya başlamıştı.
Gazetede yazılarım,
sanat dergilerinde denemelerim ve öyküm;
Kurşun Asker ile Balerin.
Kırmızı bir elma gibi
şehvetle hayatı ısırıyordum ve
gece yarıları İstanbul'un boynuna
bir öpücük konduruyordum.
Madam Anahit ile dostluğumuz ayrıydı.
Bir kambur balina zerafetiyle
meyhanelerin arasında süzülürdü.
Bir masaya yanaştığında,
Papatya Gibisin Beyaz ve İnce'yi çalardı.
Cavit'in yerine yalnız başına
gitmeye başlamıştım.
Asma katta her zamanki masamda
oturur, saatlerce okurdum.
Okyanuslara açılmıştık artık.
Köşedeki balıkçıdan alınmış füme uskumru,
az beyaz peynir, iki duble rakı.
Masanın üstünde yanyana
duran nöroşirurji yazıları
ve Latin Amerika'nın kesik damarları.
Kortazar, Márquez, Borges ve
beni kalbimden yaralayan öyküleri.
Graffiti, Karda Kan İzlerin,
ve Yolları Çatallanan Bahçe.
Kendimi okuduğumdan beri
zaman labirentlerine atıp durduğum
ve her seferinde yolumu yitirdiğim
o muhteşem öykü.
Madam meyhanenin kapısından girdiğinde,
beni görünce Mazi'yi çalardı.
Mazi kalbimde bir yaradır
bahtım saçlarından karadır
beni zaman zaman ağlatan
işte bu hazin hatıradır
ne göğsünde uyuttu beni
ne bûseyle avuttu beni
geçti ardından uzun yıllar
o kadın da unuttu beni
Sonra gelir yanıma otururdu.
Şevket acilce iki bardağı yetiştirirdi.
Ben bir parça peyniri tabağına bölerdim.
Konuşmya başlardık.
Herkesle içmezdi Madam, benle içerdi.
Birbirimize anlatacak
hikayelerimiz olurdu.
İstanbul'un muhteşem kadınlarındandı.
Bedeninin bir parçası olmuş akordeonu,
iki yanağında elma şekeri gibi iki allık,
kırmızı ruju ve her zaman
gülen gözleriyle konuşurduk, anlatırdı.
Bir beni gördüğünde, bir de kalkarken
Mazi'yi mutlaka çalardı.
Bana bir defanın yetmediğini bilirdi.
Belki de kendi için çalardı bilmiyorum.
Ama sonuna kadar beraber söylerdik.
"Ben de gönül çektim eskiden
yandı hayatım bu sevgiden
anladım ki bir aşka bedel
gençliğimmiş elimden giden
önünde ben geldim de dize
yar olmadı bu kimse bize
en nihayet düşüp can verdim
gözündeki yeşil denize
sarmadımsa da belden,
geçmedim bu emelden
bir hazin maceradır
onu aldılar elden
başkasına yâr oldu
eller bahtiyâr oldu
gönlüm hep baştan başa
viran bir diyâr oldu"
O 7 Aralık 2013 gecesinde,
Spirit of Sydney'de,
bir fotoğraf karesinde,
ben bütün mümkün geşmişlerimi ve
mümkün geleceklerimi yeniden keşfettim.
Deniz çırpıntılı, hava soğuktu.
Penguenler mır mır konuşuyorlardı.
Kocaman bir buzdağı infilak etti,
buzlar Güney Okyanusu'na saçıldı.
Spirit of Sydney deliler gibi sallandı.
Başka bir kent bulamayacaksın
demişti Kavafis.
Bu kent peşini bırakmayacak.
İstanbul yanıma geldi,
birbirimize sarıldık.
Biz bu kenti çok sevdik çocuklar.
Kaldırım taşlarını okşayarak büyüdük.
Meyhanelerinde tangolar söyledik.
Sokaklarında sırıl sıklam aşık olduk.
Sevdalımıza şiirler yazdık, şiirler okuduk.
Meydanlarında fena halde terkedildik.
Yağmurlarında aşkımızı kanadık.
Gözyaşlarımız akan kanımıza karıştı.
Sonra kısmet oldu.
Bangır bangır Mazi çalarken,
bir ağır poyrazda, tangodaki kız,
maziden çıkıp yanıma geldi.
El ele tutuştuk.
Bembeyaz yelkenlerimizi açtık.
İstanbul mavi patiskadan
elbisesini giydi.
Sabahlara kadar dans ettik.
Haliç'te bir vapur vuruyorlardı,
yemyeşil bir ay gökte dağılırken.
(Alkış)
Çeviri: Hakan Akgün